how do you transport energy from wind
farms in the north
to households in the south what if you
live in a remote region
how does energy get to your home
parliament wants to make sure our energy
supplies are reliable and that every
region in europe
is connected when it comes to gas
electricity or oil
european countries depend on each other
but also on suppliers beyond eu borders
we need this trans-european
network in the field of energy in order
to
diversify our supply not
to be dependent on one source
this interconnections will help the
diversification
and we could bring gas and other sources
of energy
from other parts of the world and of the
continent to meet its bold climate and
energy targets
the eu will have to adapt legislation
prioritizing renewable energy is one way
to reach these goals
this is why it's crucial to update the
trans-european
energy network funding guidelines the
goal of trans-european energy networks
is to develop the internal energy market
while connecting remote regions of the
eu it also aims to enhance local storage
capacity
and close cross-border gaps in the
network now
parliament wants to add a climate
dimension to the project
to make the green deal a success achieve
the ambitious carbon neutrality goal
and ensure our energy sources are secure
and diverse
all sectors must move towards greener
[Music]
solutions